là haut durant quinze ans les
expérimentations se sont succédé
nombreuses dans tous les domaines des
sciences
la hausse est la station mir fleuron de
l'industrie spatiale russe
de 1986 à 2001 la station orbitale a vu
passer des scientifiques du monde entier
d'abord des soviétiques puis très vite
d'autres nationalités
en 1987 le syrien mohamed paraissent
devient le premier cosmonaute étranger à
se rendre sur mir mohammed fares 36 ans
lieutenant colonel de l'armée de l'air
syrienne participa pendant les huit
jours de ce vol
au programme d'expériences scientifiques
à bord photographie et observation de la
terre
après mohamed fares c'est au tour d'un
français d'aller sur mire jean loup
chrétien premiers astronautes européens
à visiter la station russe le 9 décembre
il réalise une sortie extravéhiculaire
pendant six heures là aussi c'est
historique
la france devient le troisième pays à
réaliser cette opération
après l'urss et les états unis jean loup
chrétien benoît tu veux partir étaient
pieds là que sur le câble et toi à sacha
ça marche pour toi car la chose ça va
mais quand même
heureusement qu'on était là pour faire
le boulot
les années passent les programmes de
coopération spatiale s'enchaînent 1991
la britannique helen sherman biologiste
de 27 ans est sélectionné parmi treize
mille candidats elle devient la première
femme à aller sur vire bien sûr il peut
y avoir des imprévus des choses qui ne
sont jamais arrivées
mais nous sommes bien préparés je ne
crois pas que j'aurais peur on verra
samedi
côté français claudie andré deshaies est
la première femme à rejoindre la station
orbitale le 17 août 1996 la scientifique
y restera sept jours dans le cadre de la
mission franco russe cassiopée
c'est très peu s'il vous plaît
en 1999 mire accueilli sa dernière
mission
au total 104 astronautes de 12 nations
différentes se sont succédé sur la
station spatiale russe
trop cher vieillissante elle s'est
désintégré au-dessus du pacifique le 23
mars 2001 il ya tout juste vingt ans
[Musique]